hey guys Marvel just came out with a new
Avengers infinity war trailer on TV
tonight in this video I will show you
the new trailer and I'll go over each
new scene clip by clip
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so we only actually have a couple of new
scenes here but the first one is just
really awesome the scene is a fight
between Scarlet Witch and Proxima
midnight for those of you who do not
know who Proxima midnight is she's a
member of Thanos as Black Order she is a
master of hand-to-hand combat has super
strength but most importantly she has a
lance that transforms into unavoidable
toxic light beams which we see her
wielding here in the clip we actually
have a scene in one of the first
trailers that was released of Proxima
midnight throwing this Lance at Captain
America this scene kind of goes against
the comics because again her Lance's
supposted being unavoidable but we see
her throw it at Captain America and he
simply dodges it and grabs it this could
simply be Marvel taking a different
approach with the MCU than they do with
the comics which they have been known to
do or is Captain America somehow super
strong just like we've seen in one of
the previous trailers where Captain
America is actually resisting Thanos
with the Infinity Gauntlet on with two
Infinity stones in it this leaves us
with a question how is Captain America
so strong could it possibly be that he
has the soul stone this is just
speculation and rumors going around so
I'll be curious to see what actually
happens in the movies also in the comics
Proxima midnight is actually killed by
hella so either he'll is going to come
back or Marvel is just simply taking an
entirely different approach to the MCU
version of Proxima midnight the next
news scene we have is the guardians of
the galaxy doing their thing this is
more of a comedic scene than anything
but it does show us that teen group
doesn't seem to be too different than
any human teenager and he's got some
sass it's funny to see star-lord take on
the father figure role here - teen Groot
and it's funny to see teen group give
him some sass
I don't speak Groot but judging off of
what star-lord said and the reactions of
the rest of the Guardian he's throwing
some nasty words out there then we just
have this very short clip here of Doctor
Strange working his mystical arts and we
know from the other trailers that we've
seen he's helping out star-lord here on
Titan so those are all the new scenes
from the new infinity war TV spot
trailer what do you guys think of the
new scenes and what are you most excited
for an Avengers infinity war let me know
what you think in the comments below and
be sure to drop a like and please be
sure to subscribe to my channel to stay
up to date on
Avengers infinity war Marvel and all
things superhero thank you so much for
watching
woof woof